NAVAL SHIPS AT SEA, WE AND CONT
>> Randy: THE IT AHEAD.
TYLER CANNOT GET HIS TAKE JUST
IN THE FIRST PERIOD
ORIGINAL PANTHERS
SQUAD BACK IN 93.
GUYSALMOST EVERY
23rd AND 24th.
SOSOAND OH, LOOK AT
THAT.
NOW THE PANTHERS ARE UP TO 300
GOALS ON THE COND IS IS ON THAT
CHANCE!
WE GO ME
SHOTS HERE IN THE SECOND, AFTER
BEING TOTALLY SHUT DOWN IN . SA
AND HE WILLIT'S IN.
PLACE OVER TOPICKED UP BY TERRY
GET IN.
THE BACKHANDER SAVES,  IT ON TH
BY GIBSON.
UIGHUR HAS TO HIM, AND HE
AND HIS eve: HERE COMES JONATHA
HUBERDEAU OVER THE BLUE LINE.
THAT WENT INTO THE CORNFIVE-MAN
CHANGE.
THE
WAS OUT IN FRONT.
THEY MAY HAVE GOTTEN A STICK ON
IT, S SPOT.
PRODUCED A GO-AHEAD PANTHERS
SCORING CHANCE.
WE WILL TATATHEM AT
ABOUT HALF THEIR GOALS IT
2-2. MONTOUR CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
>> Randy:
GIROUX WINDS UP.
GIVES IT TO  DUCLAIR.R.OF PLAY.
>> Randy: IT IS A SHOOTING
GALLERY OUT
NOTICE GIROUX PLAYS.
THE SECOND ONE WITH 15 SECONDS
PANTHER'S 50th SHOT ON GOAL.
>> Randy: AND SACRIFICE AND THE
HE WILL SHSHTHE NET HIT
THE YEAR.A SHOT?
BELIEVE IT. BENNETT . AND
HERE COMES BRANDON MONTOUR TO C
DUCLAIR.